foreign
[Music]
it's great to be everyone here my name
is Jason Davenport I am a developer
advocate so today we're going to cover a
few things first off we will talk about
generative AI all the cool things that
you can do with it but more importantly
how do we actually create those rubrics
of things that we want to do and get
that value from from Ai and all the
things with it next to talk about some
of the different tools that we've
recently announced here at Google Cloud
for doing different things in generative
AI and then last we'll actually pull
together and we'll do a couple short
demos using some of our AI products here
actually in the console and and see some
of the cool things that you can
hopefully go and unlock after we're done
with the session today
and I also leave plenty of time for a q
a here for folks who are interested in
that as well
all right
AI it's really it's the thing that's The
Fad that will disappear in six months no
just kidding
um
we could only hope right and we could
just go back to ml and stats and all the
the fun things that are the foundations
now if you think about you know where
we've where we've come you know
especially in 2023 with the Advent of
all these large language models
you know the thing here that we're
always trying to think about as we
introduce new technologies and changes
is how do we get three things really
really accomplished first how do we
think about how we can do more with the
same or less you know everyone here has
has hundreds of things that we're trying
to do and we're always trying to unlock
and figure out ways to do things more
efficiently do it better do it with
higher quality
next how do we actually innovate so in
this case how do we do things that we
haven't done before you know whether
that's novel to us novel to our
organizations or maybe novel to society
and all those practices
and third and I think this is you know
one of the more interesting things with
with all this new technology is how do
we actually think about differentiation
so you're doing things like what are
what are different Industries to go into
what are different things from my own
skill set that I wasn't able to do
before how can I do those things and do
those those well and effectively in
those processes
however we have this this this new
pillar which is incredibly important
with with olms and AI in general which
is how do we do this securely and at
scale because what we don't want to see
is uh someone goes to Bard and plugs in
a question and they understand that
Jason Davenport lives in Denver Colorado
immediately that would obviously be very
bad
you know none of us here I think are
alone in this journey
um we did a survey 91 of organizations
are are actually trying to increase all
these Investments
um but really if we think about you know
tensions and things that are coming
against this
yeah only 20 percent of organizations
are actually realizing use cases and and
really then the question is
you know as as analysts as scientists as
Engineers how do we close this value Gap
because if we have 91 percent of of our
companies trying to do these things but
we're only deploying 20
well that's obviously a very low
realized realized rate of of getting
value from all these different models
interestingly
um five years ago I think this was
almost the same for base ML and so the
question is really how do we unlock some
of those Trends and really get that
value you know moving forward
I love these things because when we
start talking about trillions of dollars
it becomes immediately immaterial to all
of us in the room
um
I know trillions right it's it's crazy I
think here you know as we see more and
more of these statistics about new use
cases and productivity and all that
the question that comes to my mind is
how are we using generative AI for for
the powers of expansion and
differentiation and we'll show some
examples of how we can do things using
you know productivity enhancements but
really you know here here are the the
goals to grow and then how do we make
sure that we're doing that with the
right tools and that you know some of
these value things like honest quite
honestly I think there was a slide like
this probably of data Lakes back in 2008
or 2009 and you know the thing here is
is the way that we will unlock these
things and do more cool things with is
not by doing the same things that we're
doing today it's unlocking those new use
cases that we never had the opportunity
to even consider in the past
nope
sorry I messed up the clicker all right
so why do large language models actually
make these things more effective first
if we think about lom's as emergent
Technologies you know what this really
means is that you know as an engineer I
can also do things like ad marketing
copy you know that was not something
that we could do before the Advent of
this without either you know a lot of my
time spent on doing something or me
having the direct uh you know worker
knowledge for that
second you know with llms we also you
really have this contextual
understanding of language and where this
becomes really important is if you think
of the relationship between cats and
dogs
you know as as humans you know we can
infer the middle part of that right you
know maybe the dog chases the cat you
know maybe the cat and the dog you know
they they live in the same house
before llms we knew that we had cats and
we had attributes of cats we knew that
we had dogs and attributes of dogs but
to fill that that kind of chasm in the
middle and understand the intents of the
two entities was very difficult even in
things like you know bird models and
those things that came prior to those
and so with that now that we can
actually understand that context we can
unlock new experiences for this
then last and really coming to that
connection piece is if we think about
all the data that's available LM is
really kind of if we can direct them
effectively or how we can unlock all
that opportunity and understand
relationships that may not be
immediately apparent to us just because
of the volume of data that we have to
have to get through I think here as we
think about you know now we're getting
into the kind of the activation space
and you know how do we get to jobs and
and tasks that may be useful for for LM
use cases
probably the the main thing here I would
call out is that um
you know llms in the information economy
are really the things that we're looking
to to say okay how do we take the
information economy to to that next
iteration or that next generation and
you know as as I think we've all seen
you know changes changes never a linear
function changes always step wise you
know what are the stepwise things that
for example myself as a software
engineer I will be able to unlock moving
forward or what is my customer
experience going to be that really makes
the makes it more impactful
so if we think about that you know we've
started going from roles now let's talk
about how we're going to actually break
apart these things into maybe jobs the
users might perform and think about you
know from those jobs or tasks how we can
then actually get to do some sort of
scorecard for prioritization and
actually using OMS for this
uh here and this is using a popular
framework called jobs to be done for
those who are interested it's a it's a
really great way of just breaking down
the activities that we do and and the
value outcomes that we're trying to
drive with that
but thinking through here you know if
I'm a marketing you know user I'm a
maybe a data engineer supporting
marketing you know what are the things
that might benefit from using an llm for
building something like marketing and
social copy as a developer or engineer
you know one of the the things that we
always see right is it's you know
testing is great testing is always the
last thing that I do and as a result of
it testing has never actually put into
my code you know documentation is always
something where it's it's a nice to have
and I document it when it's painful but
you know everything else I don't
so what are those things right where you
know we we inherently May assign value
to that but we have not been able to do
do to date at scale that we may actually
want to think about as those those first
things to go through and then last but
not least you know coming to a knowledge
worker you know what are maybe things
that I can't do with my data you know
that an llm may be able to help me do
um things like anomaly detection where
you know I can I understand what
anomalies are based on my current
understanding but what if I just gave
this to something else or this data and
said hey what are what are the anomalies
that you see you know having having
contexts in these situations is very
important and once I can actually you
know use different contexts to my
advantage you know how do I build in
that that full Corpus of information and
and really take action on that
so let's walk through you know some ways
that we can start thinking about
prioritization of all these fun things
and then we'll get into talking about
some of those tools and value pieces
here in a little bit
first uh speaking to the last slide what
are the things that you as an individual
or you as an organization want to
prioritize as your use cases moving
forward and here
yeah I think I think there's really kind
of two ways that we've seen this go so
far right one is that we you pick
something that's you know crazy
something never never been able to be
done before you know let's try to
actually do that and use this technology
as a bridge for that the other is let's
pick something that's small but is you
know something that we can actually
measure and test and you know see the
potential benefits of
both of them are completely valid it's
also good to understand like you know
what are what's the the level of effort
I'm going to apply if it's a moon shot
or if it's you know something where I'm
looking for for incremental gains on
obviously thinking about the platform is
is very important here so what are the
technology pieces you know what are the
business processes and all those things
that go with it
and then if we start to think about you
know moving into the middle this is
really where it's okay you know what are
those those models or the the actual
large language things that I'm going to
use in order to get the get this work
done
so first obviously is okay well what are
the models that exist you know based on
my problem is this a code problem is
this a language problem is this you know
unstructured generation what are those
things with it
next is how do these models actually
perform at the core tasks and then how
are these models ultimately integrated
so you take a a very very very large
model with trillions of of parameters
and not
if my use case is sub 200 millisecond
real-time you know q a I probably have a
disconnect in terms of what my
requirements for Value are in the model
is that I'm trying to actually use for
generation
and then really here where we start to
get into is you know what are the
tailoring things that we need to do for
this and you know first question like do
I actually need something that's custom
or can I use things you know like like
prompt inputs or you know context
setting to actually make the LM
effective without all the additional
costs occurring with something like
custom Training
and then ultimately and
you know I think this is where you know
we've really seen a lot of momentum in
in the past six months in terms of
trying to build a common understanding
for this technology is you know how do I
ultimately keep my data safe and keep my
data safe within my organization safe
and then keep my customers data within
my organization safe safe for that
and so we
you know here here and I can't stress
this enough this is where we're really
trying to think about how do we bring
compute or the AI compute to data versus
taking data to the to the AR compute
because ultimately the data is the high
value thing and what we want to make
sure of is that we can we can keep it
and say keep it safe keep it in
residency keep it in all those things
that matter for it
and when we do all these things what we
ultimately can do is start to close that
that gap between the data pieces and the
business questions that I have and then
the actual value propositions or the or
the the opportunities that I see in
order to close that and here it's really
built on again the premise of you know
let's bring AI to data
let's unify those pieces together so
it's it's a great experience and then
let's bring the ecosystem partners and
pieces into that so it's very easy and
straightforward to do for for our work
all right fun things right a lot of
things that we have to think about in
terms of prioritization but let's talk
about things as Engineers that
ultimately we find super cool which are
tools we get to use in order to do cool
things with loms
so
why do people first come to Google right
um if folks here I assume many people
are working with with tools like
bigquery really you know we are trying
to bring make a data and AI first
version of cloud in order to do all the
cool things that we believe the next 10
to 20 years of of business problems will
require to be solved
uh next you know we really try to make
sure that we're bringing that compute to
your data regardless of where of where
it is so using things like bigquery Omni
to run in place in your data and another
cloud or doing something like a spark to
be able to run on an edge node uh where
your data actually resides
and obvi I think here you years of
research having gone into this both you
know for our work and then to benefit
the larger community in LOM pieces
ultimately yielding a highly secure data
platform for for these things to do and
not
and with that if we think about you know
that for for doing this for any User
it's really a couple core products that
we try to think of in terms of that that
initial value story and the center here
is really you know using bigquery and
vertex AI together in order to build
build use cases and build amazing things
across our different uh pieces and
stacks
so with that let's start to get into
some of the different attributes of of
the data Cloud here and or sorry the AI
Cloud not the data Cloud the data
Cloud's the other thing that I do uh do
on the side uh here for for the iCloud
what we're working with uh or working
toward with vertex AI is really having
that end-to-end experience whether
that's your initial kind of hypothesis
building or your actual production
machine learning operations platform
have a single stop shot for doing
anything that's required for AI in order
to make it more useful and more
effective for your organization
all this is built on things that we call
foundational models so you know folks
here have probably heard about palm palm
is obviously a set of foundational
models that we can use for things like
check sorry text chat code even now
getting into you know image gen for
building you know new and novel things
on top of that
and all this builds obviously on on
things like tpus and gpus where you're
you're getting the the scale of Google
but without the you know 10 million
dollar costs of infrastructure and build
out in those pieces of it and then
working up is is the experiences that we
get as developers using things like
generative AI app builder so that way we
can do things like you know tests you
are we going to get the right images are
we going to be able to actually build a
chat bot in this experience and then
ultimately integrating these things into
different platforms so you know whether
it's you know something we may provide
as Google for using something like duet
AI or why this is actually a vertical
solution where you may take a component
of this and implement it in your own
platform for customers than that
so I've said I think if we were playing
buzzword bingo I'd probably set security
five or ten times I should probably say
it a couple times more
um
it's very important to us in in all of
these things that your data remains your
data and if you think about you know
even the the new rules you know in
particular for for the EU around
customer privacy and digital privacy and
all these things
our intent here is that we we bring all
these data pieces into your parameter so
you can use them but everything always
remains secure and there's you know
things like like using service
parameters that way you know you you can
prevent things like exfiltration and
these are all all things that we provide
just out of the box in order to actually
make your data
um highly secure in whatever region you
need in order to make sure that your
your work can be done
all right so we first talked about uh
what are the what are kind of the
foundational components that we have the
next thing that we've we've been
launching and you've probably seen a lot
of these things you know in in briefings
and new things is is duet AI so do Nai
is essentially you know our chat bot for
you as developers or analysts to be able
to do different things uh and and have
really powerful AI driven experiences
for that
and ultimately you know our job here
with this is to help you be more more
effective and more productive and with
that what I'm going to do is I'll cut
over we have about a two minute video
because there's so many different
components of this and and using these
are really effective in terms of just
conveying you know what are all the
things and the personas that we can we
can actually work with with the way they
around so I will cut over here to that
and dance
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
here talk a little bit more about one of
those areas in Duet which is uh
obviously one that I I spend a good
amount of time with and that's you know
how do we use dueta and bigquery and all
the things we just talked about so uh
here what we're we're seeing is just a
little a movie here on the side is how
can we actually use real-time completion
in order to go through and to start you
know making essentially in this case a
pi spark document
and here you know what what we're using
duet AI for is is kind of those inline
things where you know if if I think of
my own coding pattern you know quite
frankly what it usually resides with is
is me having two screens open and one
with the thing that I'm writing and one
with the Internet is the search engine
on there and trying to just make sure
that I can get the right pieces in place
and here you know this is really where
if we think about you know the
experiences that we can power using
using tools like duet AI is you know
ultimately what we want is how can we do
everything in in one window do it
effectively and and do it in a way that
that makes sense to create that value
and you're using here things like SQL
completion and python completion are
really ways that we're trying to make
this easier for practitioners to do more
uh
you have had the pleasure of working
with some large organizations like
L'Oreal
um and here you know I think that the
the key takeaway of all these things as
much as we love to talk about tech is
ultimately what we are doing is using
Tech to help engineers and to help
companies do better things uh with AI
and always exciting to to have
organizations that we can work with on
on such fun use cases to to grow and and
to build together
so uh next thing here is is and I would
encourage everyone to try it once we get
out of here is is generative AI Studio
which we just introduced
and here uh using generative AI Studio
this really just gives us that authoring
place to start building you know
interesting llm experiences and make
sure that those prototypes make sense uh
one of the things I always think about
is you know if it's going to take me two
months to build a thing well how can I
validate you know in 15 or 30 minutes
that this is something that that's worth
my time and I found you using this is is
well one it's it's kind of fun right
because I can start making images of
really crazy things but it does help me
to make sure that my value cases and
things that I'm building are are useful
in that
and all those foundational models so we
talked a little bit about Palm for text
Palm for chat the other things here in
the bottom and and what we saw with duet
is you how do we then bring things like
code completion and Kodi you know into
your coding environment
so um if you think of all the surfaces
that we have is is interfaces to doing
uh you know code and other development
work
Cody here is really how do we then make
sure that you if you're working in our
console if you're working in Visual
Studio code if you're working another
IDE that again like we are bringing the
compute to where you are as the
developer we're bringing the to your ID
to your data and ultimately helping you
get more done
and what this will yield uh is is really
the next generation of both vertex Ai
and the bigquery platform
so uh obviously there's a lot of fun
things we could talk about and we could
probably talk for hours about ml Ops and
you know how do we make things run
production
the other thing is you know how do we
make it easy to serve all these models
at scale and using things like model
Garden you know having better prompt
design and tuning support and generative
AI again it's it's really based on the
learnings that we've had so rapidly over
the past nine months and sharing that
with everyone in order to to build great
things
so with that uh what I'm going to do is
I'm going to cut over to my my laptop
here and we're going to do a couple
quick demonstrations so the first one
will just be one of you how how is duet
Ai and the console work uh how do we get
to see some of the things that we can do
even in terms of generalized question
and answer that we can give it and then
the other one it will walk through being
able to actually use an llm in some of
our data analysis but for using it to
actually do a an unstructured data
analysis with some data to make some
sense of it so with that I'm going to
cut over here
all right
and my screen is up here so uh just for
contacts where we are I've started off
here I am in the the home page for
Google Cloud
and as we can see here I have a little
chat bot which is duet AI which I can go
ahead and open so I will do that
and so one of the most common things if
we think about data analysis is you know
what are all the things that available
to me in order to actually perform data
analysis
and so you know something we may we may
consider is okay well what are the
generalized things that I may want to do
and then what are the products that I
may want to do with that so I could do
something like
what should I do for data analysis
what we can start doing is start just to
build some some generalized
understanding for different things we
can do and you know here what we're what
we're seeing is the response is hey well
we can actually use bigquery but there's
a few other services that we started
talking about you know maybe you know we
talk about Real Time with data flow you
know maybe we also we're we're an open
processing shop and we want to do things
with spark so I can see that I'm
starting to get some product Association
based on the intent of the activity that
I'm looking to drive
in this case you know you may want to
learn more about bigquery so what is
bigquery
cool it's a fully serverless data
warehouse awesome uh what what is that
well how would I source that
you hear we also try to do a lot of
inline hinting so um
I think one of the really important
things with with llms in this case no
different than any other one is how do
we actually provide citations for
information because when we can provide
citations that means that the olm is
probably not making things up I said
probably to that because there are
sometimes times when that happens
um great so I know what bigquery is and
in this case we want to do some
unstructured data so how would I get
unstructured
data and bigquery
whoa that's a lot all right let's break
this apart because I just got a lot of
great information here
so essentially what this is telling me
is that I can use bigquery I can use
data transfer service or I can use the
storage API to help upload a lot of data
into bigquery and then here are some
different ways I can do it and how I can
analyze it I could also obviously come
through and I could start to look
through things like you know what is the
actual unstructured documentation and
the goal here right is isn't necessarily
that we're going to give the the answer
right we're not going to say hey what's
two plus two well it's four like that's
a very deterministic thing in
undeterministic things here is how are
we bettering the the practitioners
understanding how are we giving you the
right links to find things faster and
then ultimately create that value as a
part of those statements
all right so we've started figuring out
what are some different things that we
want to do with this you know let's say
I actually have some SQL now that I want
to go execute and what I'm going to do
with that is you know figure out hey
what is this actually going to do and
then how do we actually go implement it
for those
so firstly we can pull up
we can see here I have a join table and
here you know what we're starting to
work with is some sales data from our
organization
first thing I want to do is understand
you know hey of all this data like what
what does this query actually represent
uh how many times here have we seen a
query uh someone else wrote it we pulled
it up we looked at it or like I have no
idea what that thing actually represents
well let's break that apart
here I can click this little button
and what we've actually done is is is
use some contacts so we've said to to
duet
here's the query now take this and
actually explain it to me and and kind
of practitioners terms of what's
actually happening
so here we can see what we're actually
doing is we're finding in this case
because we're using group buys and Order
buys we're finding the top 10 users in
the space and and all the different
sales attributes that they have with
that
so we can see here that it writes this
out and while sometimes this may look
longer than the query that we're
representing what we're doing here is is
trying to just make sure that we can
build that that natural language
understanding of what the query is
performing and not
so next yeah let's say then the you know
I have that sales data and I'm going to
go build a what is a bigquery machine
learning model in this case an arima
forecasting model so what we're going to
do is we're going to have this model
it's going to execute
and then the thing that I actually want
to get from that is you know how do I
actually get a query that says okay you
know I want to iterate on this model
so if I were to run this and I ran it
because it takes a minute or two and I
figured you you don't want to have me up
here trying to
um you know tell jokes or any of that
that would be bad for everyone
um you know I'm not going to run that
but maybe let's say here you know I want
to understand you know what is an arima
plus model
cool I have some information that's
displayed and so basically it's saying
you hey what's a Remo why is this one a
little bit different gives me the link
to do that in this case what I want to
do because I actually want to get a
forecast off of that
we can see here that just by typing in
this intent and think of this as kind of
like a chat turn as soon as I do this I
hit enter there's a little wheel that
spun and then I actually get my query
back here that I could execute in order
to get that forecast
and here we can uh we can see the
results
as we pull it up
all right pretty cool right so we've
started just taking some of those
different engineering workflows we've
done you know a little bit of data
analysis uh we've used an llm to kind of
help help get these things through let's
talk about one more use case then which
is you know instead of having that llm
help us drive productivity how do we
actually use an llm to create some some
more value statements from from
different things that I may have
in this case what we'll do
and here I just have again some simple
SQL on a script let me go ahead and make
it slightly larger
there we go
so what we're going to do in this is we
actually have some speech files and here
um
you're working with unstructured data is
is kind of a hard activity right like
it's a bunch of wav files it's a bunch
of MP4s MP3s you know things like maybe
I get off of like a tech or maybe I get
off of a customer call or some other
video that may come in well what I need
to do is actually figure out how I can
analyze these better in a scale so the
first thing that we have here which you
can execute is just building an external
table that actually is an object link
table in order to pull all that data
into bigquery for analysis
so when I create this all that I do then
is I have that object table and now I
can use all the cool things in bigquery
in order to actually bring computation
to my unstructured data in that
so what we can do is if I were to do
something like see what's in that speech
files table
we can see here you know here are some
different wav files that we have
and now what the cool thing is that
we're going to do is we're going to
actually run a statement
we're going to encode this using a chart
model and that would be just using this
this statement here and then what we're
going to do is we're going to actually
use an LM against this data so we're
going to help summarize all of this text
into a few things that we can display
so with that
um let's say I have that have it in
these things
here I have my generate text statement
so using a single SQL function we can
actually go through and we can pass in
what what our prompter our question is
I can give it some text as an inputs so
this is the context that I'm going to
apply
and then we can also do things like tune
the model so you know how much how
creative do I want the model to be
versus
um you know drier dryer fact based you
know what are some of the other things
that I want available and then what are
your output tokens so how much do I want
the OM to come out
and then when we have all those in what
we can do if I run our last piece here
as we can see that I actually have one
of my results
and here I have the content so what the
llm summarizes is is the key things that
happen in the conversation and if we had
any categories for things like um you
know unsafe things like violence or
safety or something else we would have
those here with with scores also
displayed in terms of of that severity
so here again making it easier as you
start to interact with these things
understanding hey if this is a safe
thing maybe it's okay that it goes out
anything that's questionable and maybe I
have a human in the loop to review and
to get these things for it
all right so what have we done today
um in this part we just summarized up
how we can use duet and we've also
started talking through some of the cool
use cases where you think about bringing
those those vertex a models to bigquery
that we can use in order to build build
really interesting and valuable things
for organization